hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I'm watching Jupiter ascending I
was in the review of this that nostalgia
critic Jupiter ascending review I played
Cruella Deville
but I have not seen the film I'm excited
I hope it's fun I hope I just watch in
awe of the massive massive fail that
this movie was and I'm very excited for
it honestly I'm going into it stoked so
let's just files just do it you know
[Music]
that was garb man oh man did they spend
way too much money on CGI that looks
like crap
it was literal shit and I loved it I had
such a good time watching this film
let me just read some of the opening
lines Mila Kunis has a voiceover while
things are happening on screen first of
all all I can hear is Meg from Family
Guy
having Mila Kunis as like a voiceover it
you just oh you just hear Meg okay and
I'm sorry about that I can't get over it
first line of the film is technically
speaking I'm an alien cool great start
already tonight the sky is completely
full miracle that's all the whole script
is so she's talking about her dad she's
like his name was Maximilian Jones what
that's amazing then Maximilian Jones
dies they can't keep a character around
for the entire movie and have his name
be Maximilian Jones it's just too cool
so you find that Mila Kunis has grown up
fatherless and her and her mom clean
houses for a living she leads a very
like unspectacular life she she goes
into these rich people's houses and she
like tries their dresses on and dreams
of something bigger it's like that's
happening and then over here you're on
like this alien planet that looks
terrible the CGI is nuts it's just
stressing me out watching it knowing how
much money went into the CGI and it
still looks just so so so so so so so so
bad
you've got ready ready ed main Eddie
read it and you find out that him and
his two siblings deadeyes sister and
then the hot one they're taking like
this aging serum and you
it's harvested from humans so they want
earth so they can harvest the humans
they're cool it's creepy I'm onboard
crazy how this happens but wouldn't you
know it turns out Mila Kunis Oh earth
it's crazy so at one point
Jupiter's cousin who she lives with
convinces her to sell her eggs for money
and she wants money so she can buy her
father's Maximilian Jones this telescope
doesn't I could do as much but he's
gonna take 10 grand she's gonna be at
five grand it's her eggs she's there to
do the procedure to sell her eggs and
then aliens are there to kill her and so
they're like putting this and awkward
and kind of traumatising scene because
she's like no something's wrong and
she's being like you know put under and
then she's like in the air for some
reason the aliens come out of their
human forms and then somebody comes in
to save the day
shoots aliens of Bram Bram Brown you get
the first Eddie Redmayne freak out which
I've heard so much about and the best
thing though one thing I remember about
filming the Nostalgia Critic episode is
he's like Jackie
oh my god what he stopped so Magic Mike
is the one who shows up and he saves the
day and he tells her that he's an alien
and like they go into their ship and
it's all Dave looks really bad and
that's the main thing I'm gonna say in
this entire reaction it's just it looks
really bad this movie also is just like
alien fight after alien fight after
alien fight which sounds badass right
sounds like what could be cooler than
alien find out for alien fired after
alien fight everything good in this
movie it's the worst it's just generic
muddy CGI bites and they last for like
five minutes each you're like I would
look down to my phone just be like all
right well what's happening on Twitter
you know cuz like I do not care and I
look back up and they're still in the
same fight I also really think they
missed the mark completely on the lead
character Jupiter oh man she's so
weirdly written she has like these
instincts to have funny moments but
they're not funny
she's not like heroic enough to like
pull off like the more badass parts
she's really just boring and like just
kind of flailing with the script just
made it impossible for her to do
anything I feel like it was so misguided
he gets shot she's like I want to thank
you so much for saving my life here's a
pad and read your gunshot wounds okay
cool
is that supposed to be funny is that a
funny thing Oh period jokes and then you
find out that somehow Jupiter its
royalty
fight it out cuz the bees are buzzing
near her these consents royalty and it
just they could they gravitate I had no
oh please let me bleed out then there's
a big fight again and one of the
characters says beeswax really seriously
and that's a word that can't be said
seriously and I've said it once I'll say
it a thousand times
can't say beeswax seriously you also
keep looks like junk rat follow me on
Twitch so then Jupiter's take into the
sister's house and it's like so weirdly
formula it's not even formulated because
it's never been this special film has
never been done before she's taken to
the sister's house and the sister tries
to convince her to give her the earth
then she's taken to the hot brother's
house
he tries to convince her to give birth
he's taken to Eddie Redmayne the crazy
brothers house and yeah he's trying to
convince her to sign her over and it's
like it's like okay I'm about to do it
and then Magic Mike comes in and saves
the day and I keep calling him Magic
Mike Channing Tatum that's his name but
every time it happens three different
times and it's like it's a half hour
each time and you know every time it's
not gonna happen
what so when she's at the sister's house
she's put in this beautiful dress and
immediately she's like actually I'm
feeling a little overdressed is there
any way that I could have something more
comfortable
this is what I'm talking about about the
character being very weirdly written in
the beginning she was like just gay
dreaming her little head off about
having fancy dresses on and I felt
really out of character you understand
people can change I understand if
sometimes you get the things you want
then you don't actually want them but it
just it didn't feel like that's what
they were doing you just felt like it
was like oh we forgot we added that in
like many times in the beginning and now
we're here and we just were to let that
go it was so weird like I said every
part of this movie is her about to do
something stupid
Channing comes in and saves the day cuz
he's madly in love with her somehow and
then at the end of course she doesn't
sign it away she kills Eddie Redmayne
she owes the earth somehow and yet
decides to still go back
cleaning toy you all dear
there's nothing wrong with house
cleaning but wait I just I it was a
weird it felt weird her and and Channing
Tatum are together of course and and
have a very intimate scene and honestly
sue me
his voice is very sexy so alright I kind
of believes you to the edge Ayanna says
you'll wonder why Eddie redmayne's voice
is only shouting or whispering and it's
never in between I did wonder that
Ayanna I did yes I love dogs
I've always loved dogs more just great
great great script writing for our lead
character Jupiter just when you have a
really cool dream but you try to
describe it to someone that's this movie
oh damn that's exactly what this movie
is oh you seriously just you nailed that
alright here's here's the thing this is
gonna be the prettiest dumpster fire
you've ever watched I gotta say I
thought it looked terrible it looked
terrible the acting was very bland the
story was repetitive and didn't make
sense repetitive in like the plot device
of saving her
in just two fights the weird space
fights that were way too frequent the
acting choices that were made is so
flippin weird but those are the shots
they went with with Eddie Redmayne but
can you imagine the ones they didn't go
with that we're like oh that was a
little much go with this other shot like
it was just all such a mindfuck and I'm
so glad to have watched it thank you so
much for watching you guys I really
appreciate it do follow me on Twitch I'm
at Tamra is playing on Twitch and I will
see you all next week thanks so much
[Music]
[Applause]
you